Voici pourquoi il faut voter
Jordan Bardella le neuf/06 deux-mille-vingt-quatre.
Écoute jusqu'à la fin
celui qui va redonner des couleurs à la France,
et n'hésite pas à donner ton avis en commentaire.
Si je suis en tête,
euh, le neuf/06 au soir, je demanderai le soir même,
évidemment, la dissolution de l'Assemblée nationale.
Les élections européennes
sont des élections de mimanda.
Tout ce que vous subissez dans votre
quotidien se décide à Bruxelles.
L'agriculture, c'est Bruxelles,
la politique d'immigration, c'est Bruxelles l'énergie.
Le coup de l'énergie aujourd'hui à bissel, qui ne
correspond plus au coup de production français,
c'est décidé à Bruxelles par le marché
européen de l'énergie.
L'ensemble de ces règles européennes sont soutenus,
accompagnés, votés, mise en œuvre par Emmanuel Macron.
Moi je dis au français,
vous avez mis Emmanuel Macron en minorité
à l'Assemblée nationale en juin deux-mille-vingt-deux,
nous devons faire de même avec l'Europe de Macron
lors de ses élections européennes.
Et moi, je sollicite la mobilisation la plus large
possible pour censurer ce
gouvernement dans les.